how does it feel to finally be back
together again
coming out of the pandemic us and the
whole world I mean clearly that was the
delay between season two and three so we
wanted to make a season of Television
that was worth the wait but really not
only making the show for the fans but
actually getting to be back together
selfishly we had more fun uh just
getting back together than we did uh
before we even started shooting the show
awesome Michael what's your favorite
thing about working with these guys
ah
I guess just knowing that I'm gonna
laugh really hard every day and I and I
really mean that like we go to work and
we have a blast we work really hard we
do all our prep work
and we come prepared but we have we we
laugh really hard all day long
I love that uh Wendell I see that you've
been performing Death of a Salesman on
Broadway and John tomorrow to support
you what's it like having that support I
I didn't know Mike came too
uh it's been great I was I was nervous
you know I wanted to do great for them
you know I wanted to be on my game uh
John came this was the second time he
saw it in London as well so it was uh it
was great to have him there it was um
it's an honor to do the play every night
and it makes it even more special when
your friends come and I can't tell you
rushed it just killed it it is so good
it may be one of the most proud I've
ever been of someone within my life he
is unbelievable so if you haven't seen
the show you have to go see it come on I
love that I want to come to Michael I'm
so sorry I didn't see a photo of you no
no it's okay I know
amazing
um okay so with all of the amazing
action sequences from season one this
season three but I feel like I said
something else that I don't get no no no
no no no it's us are you sure okay no
Michael's just laughing that he wasn't
in the photos
sorry I hit it I had a nerve um
what tenth scenes oh my God
don't do that to me I'll believe you I'm
a Canadian I feel bad I totally okay I'm
totally playing I know I know okay uh
most intense scenes to shoot when it
comes to a show like this is it the card
chases like what is it
um for me yeah definitely the action
sequences are the most intense to shoot
but
um not the hardest because you always
know that it's it's for a good reason I
mean you can always sense what it's
going to be everybody takes it very
seriously and it's well thought out
um they're probably the longest things
to shoot for those tiny little moments
in the show a whole lot of prep goes
into it a whole lot of uh many many
people's hard work and then
um you just hope you don't get injured
while you're doing it and so um I think
for me the craziest one was
um I uh am thrown out of a Blackhawk
helicopter at some point it's in the
trailer so I'm not giving too much away
and um that was not supposed to be me
the um stunt guys in the morning had
done five or six takes and done a great
job and it was one of our ex-navy seals
who were lucky enough to have
Consultants from the CIA from the
military and um he said it would be a
lot cooler if you did it and I said how
would that work and he said well how it
would work is if I just unbuckled your
seat belt and threw you out right now
and he did right then and there there on
the on the show his name is Kevin Kent
and he should be in jail
wait a minute so you weren't really
prepared for that
well and you can see it on my face when
it happened oh yeah
but it made for a really great scene
right right there you go that's cool
amazing I got the wrap but thanks so
much guys you're fun thank you